have seen that in the United States mass  shootings have become more deadly over  time and it seems to be directly related  to this there seems to be too much  demand for Fame in America Langford  writes and not enough Supply we see  people posting videos and and outrageous  statements to get attention mass  killings is just the most extreme  version of this where people aren't just  being offensive or outrageous to get  attention and they know this works  essentially this is guaranteeing them  Fame and Celebrity Status one of  langford's studies found that winning a  Super Bowl or Academy Award garnered  less media attention than committing a  high-profile Mass killing perpetrators  get pictured more on front pages than  their individual victims and there's a  strong correlation between the number of  victims harmed in these attacks the  amount of media attention that  perpetrators receive  foreign  [Music]